tori have you ever met the hot guy in
the foam cannon party in cancun on
spring break no i haven't i've always
you were drunk he was cute and one thing
led to enough never i've always gone for
beta provision emails but
um i understand the dichotomy between
the boats so what is the dichotomy
between and what alpha [ __ ] beta bucks
baby explain that uh it's the dualistic
strategy between hypergamy so you have
oh god how do you explain it like you
have the guy that you want to [ __ ] the
foam cannon party that's your alpha fox
so like what she's saying the guy that
love bombed her 20 guy probably was
alpha [ __ ] right but played it off with
the whole beta provisioning side like
let me give you this let me give you
that all that stuff so he was trying to
prince harry
yeah he's trying to pretend to be that
one she knew right off the bat
because she probably what is it called
when you have the instinct as women it's
like you
maternal intuition into intuition that
this guy is probably not safe so so
what's the beta bucks part of it that's
the guy that's gonna give you
um
babies boyfriend material
what can an alpha also be that guy
balance right yeah i argue that
you're gonna meet either the alpha guy
or the beta guy it's almost impossible
to meet one that encompasses both so
what girls mostly do is they're even
when they think they lowered their
standards they were probably [ __ ]
with the 20 percent dude
do have you ever thought about a guy
that you're like damn i lowered my
standards this guy was a piece of [ __ ]
something like that honestly i
i've been able to pursue pretty healthy
relationships in my life
um which is why this one only lasted
about a week because it was like
immediately no but i don't know i it's
hard for me to die did he creep you out
why did he why did you guys break up
like you're so i i was i was telling him
i need you to uh take a step back
because it's a little bit too intense
for me and he was like yeah i know
whatever and then i went out with
friends and he like bombarded me with
text where are you what are you doing he
was the jealous type the possessive type
yeah and then i said to him uh never
said peace and love i don't think this
is it for me anymore in a text yeah you
hit him with a peace and love i always
say that peace and love oh that hurts
not interested but um
you already you've already dated them
you've already slept with them
and you hit them with a peace and love
yes and i'll tell you what i do think
this is a controversial opinion that i
have i think that text messages are
actually a great way to um convey your
feelings in a really good set way where
emotions aren't getting too involved
because you can look at it and
understand it reread it afterwards if
you want to meet up and have a
conversation that's perfectly fine i
just i need to say my piece
got it how old were you this was uh this
year
yeah and i also i just say i don't know
i know this is uh terms that you guys
use all the time what it's hard for me
to um
resonate with the term alpha and veda i
i don't know why but i feel like
placeholder terms if you are trying
really hard to like put yourself into
one of those categories then
maybe you're you're being a little bit
too analytical about your relationships
and you need to be a little bit more
intuitive fair point would you would you
like do you make a distinction between
high value men and low value men
uh yes but i
is that what it is all it is is an
abstract yeah okay so rolo if you want
to
break down and tori help rollo if you
can chime in
these alpha [ __ ] beta bucks high value
men low value men just explain that so
the audience fully understands what
you're talking about well people get
bent out of shape whenever i use the
term alpha i hate the words
i hate it literally i have a reaction in
my body that's like yeah exactly and
because it's just the terminology if i
said high value man you'd be like oh
okay what does he mean by like honestly
even that now i'm kind of like okay well
because it because you probably haven't
met the guy who is a high value guy that
is
that you could identify those
characteristics in so when i say alpha
like people keep saying oh you guys
think you're alphas you guys are like uh
you know silverback gorillas or or
wolves in the arctic tundra or something
like no that's not what alpha means okay
it's not about like this you know
analytical animal kingdom definition of
it it is an abstract term so that we can
use that to get onto other topics so
that we can say okay there's a high
value you want to call it high volume
man fine you want to call it an alpha
fine whatever it is there are guys who
have better value higher value than
lesser men is that also a winner
a definitely a winner
it depends though because depends on how
you use it it's just a placeholder okay
so there'll be a placeholder what does
that mean so
it's an abstract term yeah it depends on
what you're talking about in the moment
i mean there are alphas that are in
prison who are drug drug dealers and and
they're anti-social alphas and then
there are pro-social alphas i use this
dif here's a good way to determine the
two okay so uh there is uh captain
america and iron man tony stark right
both alpha but both different archetypes
of alpha so you have you have captain
america who's squeaky clean and and very
upstanding very pro-social and then you
have sort of the scoundrel alpha who is
like uh tony stark iron man the same you
could say like superman and batman
batman's the dark knight he's a
vigilante he does things his own way
whereas superman is like truth justice
in the american way both alpha
but they're both like different
archetypes of that alpha so
you can have a guy who is like guys get
really pissed off at me when i start
talking about you know the the
characteristics of what makes a high
value man what makes a alpha man right
and then they'll say well um you know an
alpha to me is a guy who's you know
takes care of his kids and he's married
and he's a leader in the church he's got
his own business he's got this and maybe
he's ex-military blah blah whatever it
is and that's the the that's the sort of
superman archetype that they have and
then there's the guy who's like the
scoundrel kind of guy who does does
things his own way
and um and i tell him i say look there
are just as many alphas at church as
there are in prison right now so it just
depends on is that alpha is a mindset
it's not a demographic
[Music]
you